pour pouvoir aider les gens ont des les
accidentés parce qu'ils ont besoin
le peu qu'on peut donner je pense que
c'est important que le geste est noble
et ses agents du département n'ont pas
hésité à faire don de leur sang
chaque année à la réunion c'est plus de
neuf mille malades qui pourront ainsi
être soignés grâce aux dons de sang
en même temps que d'être au travail
d'accorder un petit peu de temps pour le
les autres épreuves dont se pose
effectivement je pense être sensibilisés
peut-être par mes parents mon père tout
notamment qui donnait pas mal donc je
pense que c'est un acte important pour
nous et pour ceux qui vont le recevoir
aujourd'hui la plateau caillou
l'établissement français du sang et le
département de la réunion organise une
collecte pour ces agents ainsi que pour
le grand public
à l'arrondissement wes nous sommes très
sensibles à cette cause du don du sang
donc avec le fs nous mettons en place de
sessions par an et on a à peu près 100
donneurs pour l'année les gens sont très
sensibles en général ce sont peut-être
les mêmes qui reviennent bon avec les
habitants du coin aussi mais nous
faisons en sorte que les agents soient
sensibilisés et qui viennent donner leur
sang régulièrement avant de faire don de
son sang chaque personne volontaire doit
passer un entretien médical avec un
médecin référant une série de questions
permet de vérifier que le donneur ne
présente aucune contre-indication faut
avoir l'âge requis entre 18 et 70 ans il
faut avoir donc pas de problème de santé
particulier
il faut
quand en forme être à être en forme se
sentir en forme après il ya toutes
sortes de pas avoir été malade un examen
au niveau des voyages et certains
voyages contre 1 tick pendant une
certaine durée
non on compose toutes ces questions pour
avoir ces critères ensuite voilà il faut
être gêné raté pour venir donner son
sang mais ça fait pas mal non en plus
même pas quand l'appli coeur et rentrer
enfin comme aiguille rentrée moi en tout
cas j'ai passé ce stade
enfin tir pour encourager les gens à
venir donner je pense que c'est juste un
petit instant à consacrer aux autres
il n'existe aujourd'hui aucun produit
artificiel de substitution au sang alors
pour sauver une vie des vies le don du
sang est primordial